[SPEAKER_00]: Nighttime on the 6th of Whale Sun, probably around 10pm in the morning, the party sits above on the beach.
[SPEAKER_00]: On the rocky cliffs, not very high rocky cliffs, you're probably, I would say, maybe 30 feet above where the wharf is, looking down on the wharf that Owen Black piloted the smuggling sloop into.
[SPEAKER_00]: So the four of you are basically sitting there.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's going to be midnight soon.
[SPEAKER_00]: You guys want to have a conversation about things?
[SPEAKER_00]: We left it lit, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: We left it lit.
[SPEAKER_00]: You left two lanterns on, one on the wharf and one actually on the mast of the ship so you could see anybody that was coming on.
[SPEAKER_00]: You're about, I would say, 150 feet away, probably just right in short bow range for a long bow.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's long range for a crossbow.
[SPEAKER_00]: Somebody on the docks would be within 130 feet.
[SPEAKER_00]: If you get onto the sloop, they would be at extreme range.
[SPEAKER_00]: You shoot at disadvantage.
[SPEAKER_00]: Two dice, you take the worst.
[SPEAKER_00]: I've got used for
[SPEAKER_02]: Eight-sided resting on Hill.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I had to keep track of that.
[SPEAKER_02]: That was my rest.
[SPEAKER_04]: You can have three short rests a day, but all the dice only recover after a long rest.
[SPEAKER_01]: Correct.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can I do a short rest?
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm only down two hit points.
[SPEAKER_01]: Actually, I don't even know if I need to.
[SPEAKER_03]: He played a song to give you one back.
[SPEAKER_03]: No, you roll for your own.
[SPEAKER_03]: You get a one die six.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think we did that.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm good, I'm only down two.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm back to full health.
[SPEAKER_03]: I used four of my dies.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, I'm back to full as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: But I gotta keep track of that four that I used.
[SPEAKER_04]: Until you take one rest, then you erase all of them.
[SPEAKER_04]: Because you can take up to three short rests a day, and you have three more dice, one ten-sided and two eight-sideds, that you can use to recover hit points.
[SPEAKER_04]: So in other words, if you get wounded a little bit, you can just use it until you recover.
[SPEAKER_04]: But after you do three short rests, you have to take a long rest.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then I believe we were going to go...
[SPEAKER_01]: I can't remember.
[SPEAKER_01]: Are we going to go down the beach or something?
[SPEAKER_01]: Because Owen Black was somewhere, or am I tripping?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, let's have a conversation.
[SPEAKER_01]: You guys are probably wanting to talk to Folsom about what's happening.